I am NOT a destroyer of companies I am a
liberator of them the point is ladies
and gentlemen that greed for lack of a
better word is good greed is right greed
works greed clarifies cuts through and
captures the essence of an evolutionary
spirit greed in all of its forms greed
for life for money for love knowledge
has marked an upward surge of mankind
and greed you mark my words will not
only save Teldar paper but that other
malfunctioning corporation called the
USA thank you very much
despite this famous speech from Oliver
Stone's Wall Street strolling the
virtues of greed excess and capitals no
one could ever accuse stone or the film
itself of doing the same thing indeed
it's because of Gordon Gekkos sermon
that we know the opposite is true if
we're all greedy we can win together
that's the essence of geckos message of
course Oliver Stone and the rest of us
know that in a connected capitalist
society greed always works at the
expense of others and when later in the
film we watch bud Fox learn how Gekko
planned to gain at the expense of his
father the moral hypocrisy of Gekko and
the film's central condemnation of
capitalist excess is laid bare but that
was then and this is and I'm zoning I
think I possessed is the oh man I keep
it 300 like the
Rhianna bitches 26 years after Oliver
Stone made wall street martin scorsese
gives us the wolf of wallstreet compare
Gordon Gekkos moral defense of excess
with these comments made by Scorsese's
protagonists Jordan Belfort I was
selling garbage to garbage men and
making cash hand over fist so I was
selling shit where I go the way I looked
at it their money was better off in my
pocket I knew how to spend it better
Belfort unlike Gekko makes no moral
argument for his greed he knows what
he's doing is wrong
he does it anyway there's no great
tragedy haunting his steps like the
downfall of Gordon Gekko or the extreme
paranoia and eventual disappearance of
one of Scorsese's other great
protagonists Henry Hill from Goodfellas
Belfort does go to prison for a short
time but as he soon discovers see for a
brief fleeting moment I'd forgotten I
was rich and I lived in a place where
everything was for sale Belfort's crimes
are met with minimal punishment both
physical and psychological and just to
twist the knife on that fact scorsese
has the man himself the actual Jordan
Belfort introduced his character as the
single baddest motherfucker I have ever
met so maybe it's no surprise that the
wolf of Wall Street was raked through
the mud by a number of critics for
glorifying apologizing endorsing
capitalists excess Scorsese's film
certainly doesn't offer the negative
critique of tragedies like Wall Street
or Goodfellas it doesn't even offer a
satirical critique of late capitalism
such as you might see in films like
American Psycho where Patrick Bateman
smooth almost enlightened exterior is
undermined by his psychopathy
self-loathing and psychological
breakdown a satirical critique of
capitalism would require the movie
itself in its tone and themes to
ridicule or expose the improper behavior
it displays but the wolf of Wall Street
gives us no such thing the joke is never
on Jordan Belfort it's on everyone else
his wife his free
his enemies and the world at large were
not made aware of some unknown
underwriting sadness quite the opposite
Belfort is perfectly disaffected by the
scummy ways he makes his money and the
debaucherous lifestyle he spends him his
personal philosophy echoes that of alien
from harmony currents spring breakers
some people they want to do the right
thing I like doing the wrong thing
everyone's always telling me yo you got
a change I'm about stacking change yeah
stacking change that's it money both
films are prime examples of what film
critic Izzy Black has called the new
cinema of excess films in which greed
and excess are explored but never for a
moment condemned indeed a key feature of
this kind of cinema is that the film
itself partakes in the excess it shows
nowhere is this more clear than in wolf
which runs for three hours and moves
from montage to montage and ever crazier
flights of hedonism
but just because Scorsese refuses to
condemn Belfort doesn't mean that he's
by extension endorsing him either excess
is excess it's exhausting it's too much
too fast Scorsese has no illusions about
this his extensive use of close-up
reveals the vulgarity of this way of
living his montages exhaust rather than
glamorized the hedonism to which were
privy is less attractive than
disorienting less desirable than
overwhelm I will not die sober
fucking lows the water Wall Street is a
descriptive project learning from its
moralizing predecessors even the
predecessors in Scorsese's own
filmography there were no bud Fox's to
take down the Gordon Gekkos of the 80s
there wasn't even anyone to take down
Belfort silk in the 90s the folly of
late capitalism got worse and worse not
hitting its lowest point until 2008 in
the financial recession and it's unclear
despite new regulations if any of those
lessons were really taken to heart the
reason for this is because the excesses
of Jordan Belfort
are our excesses like him were too
enlightened not to know the expense at
which our gazillion products are made
like him we don't really make an attempt
at moralizing away our involvement in
that system we just don't care the
disgust we feel for Belfort is
hypocritical the indignation we inflict
on him is less a righteous act than a
self-righteous delusion Scorsese refuses
to participate in that delusion anymore
and the result is a film so
unapologetically excessive that the
audience might finally realize that the
screen they thought they were watching
was in fact a camera